holy tamale that was so intense I I mean you're
guarantee a little bit I uh all right it was
just a lot oh my God you're the first person
here I think he's gotten so tense that they
started actually watering up
what is going on there citizens so I don't
know how to say citizens in Spanish of the
reject Nation Jordan once again by Tara Erickson
Tara you've been coming here for the past
few weeks what is the one movie I've been
saying we should watch this and we just never
do wreck and every time he says it I'm like
wreck like w-r-e-c-k and I always am like
nope I know what he means he hasn't stopped
talking about it here's a fun fact of my life
like annoying how much he talks about it hold
on one there's a fun fact in my life Tara
they remade this into a movie called quarantine
I saw quarantine two the straight to DVD sequel
but I never saw wreck I need to watch this
film finally so here we are I hear it's fantastic
it's in Spanish so get ready to put that American
dog in there to the test and read some stuff
today adios I'm excited ladies and gentlemen
leave a like also Tara what should they do
[Music] ring the bell full-length Reaction
watch as long as we stick with your own copy
of wreck available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page become a super section
reject check out all the stuff we cover they're
exclusively reaction highlights and watch
alongs included thank you to all of join me
in so many pledges because we've been covering
a ton of movie reactions so thank you for
your support are you ready Tara to finally
do this I am listo that means estoy liso I'm
ready really estoy listo do you speak some
Spanish what
let's turn off the subtitles [Music]
and videos
what a huge microphone that's tied on with
a zip cord
oh my God it's like filming with Tara
one take wonder I don't know what you're talking
about
that sounds like a good time heck yeah it's
gonna be a fun hour yeah
they're apparently very good Cooks
you still want to be a firefighter genuinely
because of dinners like this yeah it's one
of the community community
experience
all right
this feels very real yeah
they have a bat the whole basketball court
there too looks like it'd be so much fun to
be a firefighter this is camaraderie building
the whole time great dinners basketball courts
lots of movies foreign
we got an alarm people we got an alarm all
right let's move will the cameraman slide
down too move move move
her character Arc is she's gonna not care
what she looks like uh [Laughter] a wreck
oh well done
I wonder how much of this is improvised yeah
that's a good question because it seems so
very off the cuff and very natural
oh damn okay
holy [__] instantly so fraught damn
wow this is intense they had camera guys walking
upstairs backwards he's doing a very good
job
I
wish Michael Scott from the office was here
need to redo that take
spooky old lady
it does not matter
no thank you oh my God real sound designs
oh my God what is happening oh my God
oh my God
no
I would not turn my back to her
foreign [Music]
[Applause]
damn well done oh my goodness
oh yeah
oh damn oh turn the camera light on what what
crazy frenetic energy
oh
my goodness this is so intense this is so
real
[Applause] [Music]
easy everybody quarantine
he doesn't know get him out of there before
he bites y'all
that's true
vote
this is so anxiety
what what what what
I always spit out my drinks
oh
it was insane yeah the old lady's still up
there
yeah let the tape go buddy that's the end
of the movie terror
be careful that lady's throwing people off
the stairs this is remarkably shot
is she going back in the room yes and I don't
know why also where are the other people
no oh my God no
what's up
what is that an infected person or a turned
person she's dead she just oh God the old
lady's not dead that so yeah
okay do they just shoot her down yeah what
are the rules you have to get a head shot
she just could come back from it somewhere
in the back of her head she's like this is
a good story yeah she's gonna come up with
a script and then that lady is gonna get back
up I know it
oh I don't like it that's true there's a toy
review
oh god oh what do you why do you have to see
it yeah why yeah
her fever's gone up yeah because her dad was
out getting her antibiotics but he can't get
back in is that part of the infection no no
no she just had well
oh my God they cut off everything
don't go back up there
display I can't tell if that's just what Dreadful
sound design or if there's music
oh [__] God
what whoa
oh my God no one cares man yeah he is so not
in charge
did he just pull out his gun
so impressive with the guy going on in the
background yeah
the choices and reactions feel so authentic
yeah
that the one who fell I don't know
oh my God oh my gosh just cut through the
needle in the skies
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
this is so well crafted here like whoever
directed this and got these people to every
single one seemed like it was like in the
moment real is like Bravo [Music]
got himself already I was waiting for that
one guy
oh oh boy
this is
relatables
where is the fourth one oh my God
oh my goodness everyone hears racist against
the Chinese or Japanese people
the responses and dialogues are so real so
vividly laid out I can't I am so impressed
I can't help but like Marvel at how well crafted
this is like you're actually getting to know
them in a way that's not like Exposition driven
but just the way they're responding to things
they do a lot with a little
it's faking like the time yeah it's like television
oh Oh that girl looks dead the best thing
you can do is kill the old man upstairs and
this little girl and her dog too
me that yeah [Music]
have they still not shown us Pablo no that's
Pablo's feet I think yeah yeah I don't think
we've actually seen his face yet no
oh my God
[Music]
hey just wait to get the information man just
let him record later
kisses
lady I like you but please be quiet shut the
hell up yeah is that shot supposed to kill
him like put him down
oh yep you're in for it now oh my God [Applause]
she's up too oh not that guy that guy was
great
everybody oh my God
oh my God get out of the way
if you know espresso saliva then let them
get out
wow
oh no sir you gotta kill that dog is
oh okay yeah you gotta put her down and the
mom oh come on they wouldn't know
oh this is poor mom and daughter
[Music]
damn it
wow
[Applause] oh my God
oh the [__] father damn it oh shootings
I don't get why you can't send in more people
to help there's not enough suits Greg yeah
they're low on suits damn it I did not say
a little girl attacking the mom me neither
and it was awesome there's so much anguish
in that moment too like the mom getting hurt
and then realizing they're gonna try to take
her daughter
this apartment this one freaking room what's
the deal with this place can I know you
know oh my God she's right there I can't
do not grab a weapon
let's just get a charge at you man
oh my god oh my god dude why is it the guy
with the Hazmat suit the one doing it why
isn't the guy with the Hazmat suit another
money because he's in charge damn look at
her forehead
[Music] [Applause]
oh whoa
wow what Pablo is really getting a great shot
here
memories
oh that guy was all right in the end oh my
gosh he's alive oh my God
whoa nicely done
whoa that was scary [Laughter]
[Music]
yeah no no don't take them off
coward you're just gonna have to let the mom
die
I wanted to save her but it can't I mean she
was already gonna turn man
what the hell is that noise
God damn I hope Pablo makes out of this alive
so chaotic this is just Wackadoo Wild
ER come on catcher pull it together
oh yeah filling that off
oh yes
close that weird gate kill him
damn
[Music] [Applause] it
where foreign
come on
holy [__] this is horrifying this is a
legitimately scary man this is the most insane
thing I have watched in
a minute
stop yelling you're going to draw attention
no no not him
oh yeah [Applause] does that do the trick
all right does that work
that's why she's cuffed
wow
but the camera now Pablo thank you Pablo oh
my God
shoot them
oh my goodness okay so they just become like
super rabid
what did they turn off the lights
[Applause]
oh my goodness wow
[Applause] oh my God
the Mallet oh God oh God do it hurry up yeah
all right okay
I'll wait here what
ah should mess up her mic [Music]
just take them all
oh my God there's so many of them oh he's
right there oh
my God oh my God oh well you don't know there's
a million of them there's no way there's absolutely
no way you're gonna oh my God she found it
okay okay
foreign
oh God that is not a penthouse
oh this this is what started it religious
did he start some stuff with all this Juju
God are those all he killed these people what
is this what what's going on here yeah guns
and [__] okay he's a sociopath I mean
it looks like some type of Catholic Catholic
thing again
possession possession
ah so it's not an infection it's a demonic
thing is
[Music]
there's like a whole like mythology to this
[__]
all right just grab anything that could be
a weapon yeah like for sure like go in with
anything
[Music]
Yuri how do they experiment with putting in
the dog
I think so
[Music]
going to seal off the room okay seal should
keep her in don't break through a seal
wait is that little girl the old lit no oh
my God
what is up there wait a minute
all you ever do is close it wait like a half
hour
oh this POV I can't stand it oh boy this move
is gonna give me a freaking heart attack this
might be the scariest thing I've seen on this
[__] what's on this channel so far
so scared [Music] no uh oh my God
foreign
oh my God
y'all are dead that little girl gonna kill
y'all that was a little girl over there boy
it looks like a boy but like they were talking
about the little girl so I don't know
I can't see neither what is he even looking
at what that's a little girl oh my God
this is a little scary
what no [Music] what does what is that what
what is this
oh my God that's like some games
what the [__] oh
it's so lanky is that computer generated or
a real person because that is I can't
they're looking for a snack s
oh no oh oh thank you take the cross as you
walk out maybe it will save you
oh she's a dum-dum s
run where oh my God
ah so she like
she like grew up
ah
[Music]
goodbye Angela [Applause] [Laughter]
[Applause]
wow
oh my god wow wow holy tamale oh my goodness
I've heard for years how great that was like
damn that was so scary that was so intense
I've seen your dinner a little bit damn damn
Tara uh you're right it was just a lot oh
my God
I'm glad you agreed to do this reaction for
free today [Laughter] oh boy I feel tired
like that was so much anxiety fueling through
my system that my body is like you you lie
down now you're the first person here I think
he's gotten so tense that they started actually
watering up a little bit I gotta hear your
thoughts man I mean this Wackadoo wild one
of the best horror movies that I have ever
seen I have not seen that many it from 2018
I think that was year 2017. I love that movie
I'm always like that's my favorite this I
know it's very different but this holy junk
the acting was Stellar I have never seen like
that it's set up so well where every single
person is so very believable I just I don't
know I mean this was so believable I felt
like I was there the POV with the camera I
I'm curious how many rehearsals they had to
do or how much the director had to redirect
to be like no it still doesn't feel as real
yet or if he just found people that are just
perfect for what's happening all of it was
so believable and terrifying and I need to
know if that lady at the end was computer
generated or real because I can't well it
says digital I've mean that doesn't I don't
know I don't know what these mean looking
at these effects here or the credits yeah
uh talk about a build wow a great grip on
pacing because it starts out with that you
know the or just get it into just to think
of where how far we've come like ah we're
just documenting the firefighters fun little
cute evening new show segment we're gonna
do and the how it escalates because it reaches
this point where all houses starts breaking
loose and it's this crazy cacophony of events
of everyone turning you never know where they're
gonna come from and the movie did such a good
job at getting you familiar with the layout
of the building and the and this The Limited
space they had but the floors as well so you
had some spatial awareness of what you had
to what you had to deal with with this playground
essentially um but it it felt so claustrophobic
and yeah I mean that with found footage it's
especially with the found footage has evolved
into where they do like a lot of cool hyper
stylized things is they've got to like up
their game now this this felt like they just
got like a VHS camera yeah like recording
[__] yeah that was that was because because
so much of it just seemed to rely on what's
in camera and for these very long takes um
with some brilliant sound design throughout
it and yeah I love how you watch these characters
essentially because it's not one of those
things it's about like character Arch or anything
like that you just watch them deteriorate
over time and yeah lose their minds and there's
a sense of irony of this I I don't really
know if like I don't think this Angelo girl
deserved what happened to her obviously not
like I don't think there is but it starts
off in the middle in the beginning of the
movie where you can see as being a journalist
is going on camera there's a hint of like
vanity behind uh the performance but I feel
like that's kind of like for anyone who's
on camera you're gonna be aware of those things
especially for women um but there seems to
be like a bit of an extra emphasis on that
and and then just getting like stripped down
to her core like starts off where it's all
about presentation and then how you're seeing
her I've heard like deteriorating breakable
vulnerable stage ever back to her demise it's
it's so it's a wild film it's a very wild
film and [__] Terror I've seen so many
zombie movies and so many zombie show and
shows as well and to still be this affected
by something that is a essentially part of
the infected zombie category I think is very
impressive oh gosh so impressive like and
I just can't get over how believable everyone
was like it everything it's just I don't know
everyone was so good in this I started to
get concerned like when the firefighter got
taken out and that reveal of the stair s like
it's it's so well composed like but that was
but it doesn't feel like I'm looking at a
director doing this is gonna be my cool cinematic
shot but there are a lot of like cool cinematic
shots but it never pulls you out of the realism
you know right because it's like they showed
that shot from like they're kind of on the
they just do a swoop and you see like kind
of just a a thud like your brain just goes
oh he came from which they I guess maybe he
just like fell over onto the ground like I'm
trying to think in shooting wise but like
yeah because he could have been like I'm sure
but that would have taken us out of it if
he's shooting from like up top and we see
a guy falling it's like a lot of these things
are just cut to swoot and there it is yeah
there which um I I think you're right feeds
into the realism a lot because you can't really
actually catch those kills on camera too well
because it'll look too set up it has to just
be realistic which I'm wondering that's again
why I'm wondering how many rehearsals they
had to do to go well if the camera's here
and they're shouting how do we cut to like
him being on the ground to keep rolling and
have it seem all very just very real yeah
it's they keep you locked into the POV and
I can actually get on board with the cameraman
being so good at this because once in a while
I will get my you know nitpick found footage
brain that comes out of would he just still
keep recording I feel like you get to a point
where you're just like you gotta like by your
side you're [__] running right yeah um
however because they they put so much emphasis
on they're trying to cut they're doing something
terrible to us yeah they're not trying to
protect us you have to document we have to
document it there's so much emphasis on it
he's a professional cameraman who's such a
professional that he's trained himself to
observe solely through the lens uh of the
camera whereas like us the average person
would probably put the camera down at any
moment you know what I mean like we just started
running for it or or not care to capture it
but it's like you get the impression this
Pablo so I thought it was smart to never see
Pablo's face because you get the impression
that he he is so trained to the point where
he oh he has to he his vision is just he is
the camera yeah he becomes one with the camera
as that kind of camera operator that he is
um so I I was actually able to buy into that
because they had the the middle section where
it was slowing down quite a bit when you are
when she's like interviewing the people you
know yes that was so necessary for the a the
crazy blowout yeah wow what an impressive
film and what happened to the old people um
what do you mean we know the old lady and
the old I'm sure they're gone for I'm sure
they were one of the people die though I know
because they were oh they were probably it's
at the very end when we saw like Pablo right
where it was like Pablo then all of them on
the stair well and they're all just coming
up for them right now the firefighters I'm
sorry not Pablo the firefighter yeah
who ran up and there he was and then all the
rest of them were coming at the stairwell
unreal so fraught and like yeah it's just
it's so like it's it's oppressive and so much
anxiety and it's a whirlwind of emotions like
the part that where I was where I found myself
so impressed with the emotionality was when
the mom got cuffed oh yeah so when she's yelling
Jennifer yeah because she's she's she's just
um like wailing in pain because they know
they're gonna like try to take her little
girl but she's also suffering physically from
what her little girl just did to her yeah
it's like fear trying to protect but also
scared and rage there's just so much emotion
being blasted through it just feels like such
a such a vulnerable experience for everyone
yeah it is so good so good I I really love
this and it's been hype for me for so long
that's why people want to watch it and to
be like wow I didn't know this would be this
good I just thought it was going to be like
a well-made movie yeah this was amazing and
the cuts to Black did a lot of did a good
amount of work too like it didn't seem like
a cheat like oh they need to cut out of that
because like makeup wasn't good enough or
they couldn't do that stunt or like they couldn't
I don't know it just it worked out that's
like when it cut to Black it just made sense
yeah yeah it's a very long battery life those
cameras have you must have brought extra batteries
yeah I did wonder why they couldn't get like
some people to go in there though they were
able to send one guy why couldn't they send
like a couple of people to right and all soldiers
or whatever it is yeah swap people and even
with like the plastic I'm like oh yeah they
could just grab stuff break the Windows like
you can break through that plastic of them
if they were really if they start to really
lose it but then you'd be scared that the
police would shoot you dead right they set
it up to where like there's so many sirens
or like you have to stay inside that you kind
of would be afraid that you would maybe be
shot which is the reason why they weren't
like blowing up to get outside but
the whole time the people back there the entire
time great use of their budget so good such
a great way to do their budget because you
get this sense that there's so much so much
happening outside but really in reality the
problem
guy being like all right yeah yeah yeah you
had a great grip on harrowing atmosphere that
was so that was so well done like it's it
from from people who like want to make our
own [__] it it's kind of inspiring in
a weird way because you're like oh damn like
they did something with so little yeah that
was so [__] effect like they rented out
this bill I mean obviously the fire truck
and traveling to that cost money in the production
yeah at the same time it's mainly it's just
it's mainly One locations it's just this one
building yeah um and then all that religious
undertone [__] at the anonymous it was
just like very very much apparent that I like
the ambiguity of of how it all went how it
all got there yeah was it it's like okay was
it a scientific infectious thing that the
Vatican confused it for being demonic possession
right is it an inverse right the other thing
well I mean she looked pretty demonic at the
end like long and stretched out and the face
was it was I can't it's the thing in nightmares
as I said Del Toro horror [__] oh gnarly
the only the only one shot that I was like
oh it was so obvious that it was coming is
that when they set up the old guy by the gate
when the guy just said I've been bitten he
locks himself in he's like get out of here
right it's so funny because you're like yeah
we all just saw that guy throw the keys and
we all know he's been bit but this old guy
is trying to tell him can you hear me I get
why they set it up that like he they're like
okay so how do we get him there the guy doesn't
hear you so you have to grab him turn him
around towards you and now you're by the gate
can you hear me but I'm like uh I wish because
you know in that moment when they set somebody
up that close to the gate that he's gonna
come through the gate again yeah that was
the only thing that I saw coming and I was
like oh that that was really the rest of it
did girl biting off her mom's face didn't
see that coming uh a guy falling that stare
thing terrifying also I really didn't even
see it coming when you when we have the POV
of the two um already bitten guys on the table
you're kind of thinking like when they give
him a shot they're gonna get up but it wasn't
even that guy it like cut to like they both
got up same time and just started like losing
it and I didn't see that coming it was yeah
the movie knew how to tour with your expectations
and then went to put you solely in the camera
POV of when like something would just pop
up in frame like when that old lady who just
the the first lady yeah just doesn't die she
just doesn't stay down she doesn't die that
was there when she just popped in the fridge
Oh I thought that was so terrifying boy was
the scariest part for me I almost jumped out
of this chair yes I was so scared that I was
just frozen I had to like put my hand over
my chest I went over here like was gonna fall
over like I even though you know it's like
there's got to be something coming I just
man this movie is this movie's great that
was a great movie it's really good like if
you want it's it's the type of movie too that
you you want to like show Friends to be like
hey watch this movie right like on Halloween
like oh my God it's this little like found
footage film it's funny like it's it's not
even in English like no big deal but if they're
paying attention it's gonna be pretty terrifying
like you can sell it as like it's just like
a fun little thing but it's so it's spooky
can you imagine if we watch this with a lot
with no lights I was like oh this is already
like so such an experience no I don't like
looking around like oh my God the lights are
Robin's gonna be way more scary terrifying
yeah yeah I mean but having the headphones
on really does help immerse with it that's
why I'm I really wanted to make sure we had
headphones uh for these kind of for reactions
because that helps offset some of the light
experience because the sound pulls you in
that's why I like the volume up here I know
he liked it up so loud that's why there's
two times yeah it like hurt my ears but it
pulls you in I just want to see if wreck 2
is like liked yeah because I'm like how would
you like top like I want to see it I feel
like after this one if people are liking it
we're gonna have to do all
of them because why not
rec2 is 68 it's pretty good not as good as
this person the First on Reddit is just as
good if not better oh interesting I don't
know there's such a surprise Factor though
yeah the Rotten Tomatoes guys like not as
good as its predecessor yeah okay 60 what
did the first one have on yeah wreck
82. okay that's an audience quite a big dip
critics yeah huh okay yeah that was a nightmare
[Music] it really was I love that that was
so well done wow like whoa what a great what
an inspiring way to make a film and for found
footage this is such a genre that is like
gawked at you know people eye roll that at
found footage all the time right no this is
a cinematic experience right here that was
impressive alrighty gang well what did
you think about wreck leave your thoughts
down below let's see who the lucky one is
he's gonna get a shout out in this wreck video
today here we go Lance door Lance if
you
were the perfect one to shout out for this
because I hate to bring this up again homeboy
is a firefighter oh we just saw a movie where
a firefighter was saving the day the whole
time so if Tara and I were trapped in a situation
like this if I was Pablo who she was Angela
oh we would love for you to be our maneu please
come save us Lion's door oh you'd be a perfect
person to be trapped in a situation with and
watch you kill a bunch of people while Tara's
panicking like a wild animal yeah I'm like
calm down woman calm down great [Music]
Ness
and Lance you would be there just to yell
at us silencio and I would love that about
you yeah you're more masculine than I'll ever
be and um and then when uh the pandemic sweeps
the world of this virus infection and there's
only just you and Tara left you two will have
to repopulate the Earth yeah I hope you're
good looking hahaha
he is
[Music]